la caméra classe je te plait je pourrais
genre m'amuser avec ckoi sa cause avec
les caméras étaient foutues n'en soit
pas là dedans mais allez vas-y laquelle
faire toi 3 2 1 elle est bizarre celle
là ouais elle habite juste en dessous tu
entends ça ça vient d'en dessous et u7 à
coppola devrait la tâche et ça continue
à descendre à temps at-on foutu coupe
saut c'était qui
la caméra quelqu'un et moi c'est ma
voisine d'en dessous qui est morte eh
bien on parfois
il ya du sang partout katie et kristi
c'est quoi ça c'est des trucs de magie
noire
comment la vivez votre toit je fais des
rêves de malades mais c'est quoi
on dirait une morsure je sais pas ces
temps ci je me sens bizarre vous avez
déjà eu l'impression qu'on vous observe
tu as de la mallet ouais bouge pas les
films pas mec ça va ouais ça va and they
can
comment t'as fait je sais pas je sais
pas baird
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
c'est cathy et ça c'est christine ma
belle-mère festi a été procédé ensuite
cathy ceux qui ont la marque deviennent
des autres qu'est ce qui va lui arriver
ces poussées de nous